te ment pour en parler avec nous à
arnaud benedetti rédacteur en chef de la
revue politique des parlementaires
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors quel beau
bilan est ce que vous dressez de la
mobilisation ces dernières semaines
concernant ces
manifestations dupas sanitaires vous
l'avez dit c'est une mobilisation qui
fléchissent veulent après semaine alors
il ya vraiment plusieurs raisons qui
expliquent que ce fléchissement première
raison c'est que l'état fait normal qui
est un phénomène d'accoutumance au
au dispositif sanitaire que constitue le
passé militaire deuxième sujet c'est que
bon il est clair que la plupart des
grandes forces politiques ne se sont pas
engagés dans ce moment tipa sanitaire
donc ça limite forcément c'est d'une
certaine manière l'assiette de la
mobilisation
troisième élément c'est que la décrue de
l'épidémie et peut-être aussi houle est
ce qu'un cd l'idée que nous allons
sortir du tunnel épidémique dans lequel
nous sommes entrés la langue depuis le
mois de mars 2020 avec une question une
question qui est pourtant majeur c'est
de savoir s'ils se passaient les cartes
aura pour roger non vous savez que la
loi ilyas titus pas sanitaire met un
terme en principe au passage du ter à
partir du 15 novembre
quoique il y à des signaux assez
contradictoires qui sont émis par
d'exécutif sur la prorogation ou non de
ce dispositif justement c'était la
prochaine question nationale elle si
deux scénarios sont envisagés faire
tenir les mesures jusqu'au 31 mars où
jusqu'à fin juillet soit après les
élections législatives
selon vous comment réagiront les
français vous parler d'un phénomène
d'accoutumance
jeta vrai problème c'est à dire que la
réalité c'est qu'on a du mal à imaginer
une campagne présidentielle avait que
des mesures sanitaires restent très
contraignante a fortiori si l'ennemi
quand on nous dit que ça renforcerait
l'idée
des opposants qui eux depuis et
maintenant l'instauration de cet
instrument
livre le risque que cet instrument
s'installe dans la vie quotidienne des
françaises et des français au delà de sa
date de péremption législatives donc ça
pourrait avoir un effet au delà du
phénomène d'accoutumance que l' on
observe aujourd'hui à laisser
éventuellement de réactivation de la
mobilisation mais tout ça reste encore à
démontrer
alors vous parliez justement des
présidentielles la cote de popularité du
président elle semble augmenter selon un
récent récent sondage est-ce que
prolonger le pass annie terre est une
bonne idée à quelques mois d'élections
présidentielles c'est d'ailleurs un
sondage qui surprend vu le climat actuel
en france en janvier
vous savez il faut être extrêmement
prudent quant aux sondages que qui sont
publiées en ce moment d'abord une cote
de popularité ne fait pas un oral si
ç'avait été le cas
95 jospin en 2002 donc il faut que je
crois regardez grande prudence dans
l'analyse de ces études d'opinion l'a
été c'est que aujourd'hui de toute façon
s'il y avait un bénéfice pour emmanuel
macron en matière de popularité c'est
qu'ils le doivent récemment
essentiellement au fait que le champ
politique est extrêmement dispersé
extrêmement balkaniser et qui se nourrit
de deux shows nourrit d'abord l'exemple
des investissements citoyens dont par
exemple la désaffection électorale aux
différentes 1 constitue un exemple et il
se nourrir qui fait qu' aucune
candidature alternative a pour l'instant
réussi à percer dans l'opinion publique
donc ces deux phénomènes nourrissent ce
halo de popularité mais est ce que ce
n'est une bulle ou est ce que c'est une
réalité la question de paris à ce stade
extrêmement difficile à trancher alors
très rapidement monsieur nenê comme en
manque de temps voir des personnalités
politiques et publiques qui prennent ces
manifestations à bras le corps on voit
nos florian philippot est ce que
finalement ça peut inciter pousser les
français à défiler dans la rue
très compliqué parce que s'ils voulaient
ce sont des personnalités publiques ils
sont à la périphérie du champ politique
qui sont périphériques dans une
politique c'est à dire que ce sont des
acteurs politiques il s'agit de florian
philippot de spleen ou ou deux de dupont
aignan qui ont du mal pour l'instant
imposer leurs propres politiques dans le
champ politique donc est-ce qu'ils ont
une capacité de mobilisation au-delà
j'allais tenir de leurs sympathisants et
de leurs adhérents
c'est là aussi une interrogation il me
paraît difficile à laquelle ils
en ont bénéficié
merci d'avoir conduit à des notations se
rappelle rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire merci merci